nous avons le plaisir aujourd'hui de
recevoir Monsieur papendia ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
merci monsieur le ministre je vais
commencer par vous poser un ou deux
sujets je vous laisserai la parole pour
un propos liminaire par la suite et
ensuite nos collègues auront un premier
passage de questions en deux minutes par
par groupe et après on verra en fonction
du temps qui nous restera pour échanger
sur tous les sujets qui vous préoccupent
monsieur Miss lors de notre rencontre
avec des enfants et des jeunes à
l'occasion de la Journée internationale
du droit des enfants à l'Assemblée
nationale il y a quelques semaines ceci
avait choisi comme thème principal
d'échanger sur le harcèlement scolaire
ils ont tenu à nous alerter sur le
harcèlement qui est très important les
établissements scolaires beaucoup de
témoignages ont fait part du manque de
réactivité de la communauté éducative du
manque d'écoute et de l'impression qu'on
n'agit pas pour les aider on a
d'ailleurs pu leur parler du texte voté
l'année dernière initiative de notre
collègue Erwan Balan que beaucoup
d'entre eux y compris les
accompagnateurs ne connaissaient pas
nous savons que le projet phare existe
mais lors du coloc organisé par la
délégation sur le numérique et la
protection du mineur nous avons été
alertés par des enseignants du lycée qui
aimeraient eux aussi pouvoir participer
au programme PHARE ainsi que la volonté
de certains en collège de s'y inscrire
mais visiblement ça ne serait pas
possible partout donc monsieur le
ministre qu'en est-il et un intervenant
de ce colloque proposé une formation
numérique au numérique de 35 heures sur
toute la scolarité j'aimerais savoir ce
que vous en pensiez plus généralement au
moment où la mort du jeune Lucas nous
interpelle tous comment peut-on faire
pour mieux lutter contre ce fléau qui
gangrène nos établissements scolaires et
détruit de nombreux enfants
on voit trop souvent que le harcèlement
ne se termine pas à l'école mais se
déploie à travers internet et les
réseaux sociaux et d'autres mots s'y
trouvent également consultation facile
de sites pornographiques fake news non
contrôle des réseaux sociaux j'aimerais
savoir Monsieur Miss comment l'école
peut agir pour accompagner les enfants
dans l'usage de ces nouveaux médias
et comme nous le voyons la violence dans
la société est partout y compris dans
les familles de nombreuses enfants ne
savent pas toujours qu'on n'a pas le
droit de les frapper des humiliés et les
agresser pour les éduquer de nombreux
enfants victimes de violences ne savent
pas qu'ils sont victimes de violence et
souvent ce sont les enseignants qui s'en
rendent compte faisant d'eux les
premiers générateurs d'informations
préoccupantes et je tiens à les
remercier nous avons tous intérêt à ce
que la violence baise dans notre pays et
je pense que ça ne peut passer que par
l'éducation à la non-violence à
l'éducation au corps à la parentalité à
la vie sexuelle dès le plus jeune âge
comment envisagez-vous de rendre
réellement effectif les cours
d'éducation sexuelle et la vie affective
sont déjà inscrits dans la loi et
pensez-vous faire évoluer celle-ci pour
transformer et faire en sorte que le
socle du fer-nation porte ses valeurs et
ce dès la maternel dans notre pays
monsieur le ministre j'aurais bien
d'autres questions puisque votre
ministère est large puisqu'il comporte
j'allais dire le cœur de notre
délégation c'est à dire les enfants mais
je vous propose pour de pas empêcher et
prendre toutes les questions de mes
collègues de vous laisser une première
intervention et ensuite je laisserai la
parole à mes collègues je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre de votre présence
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation et de
nous permettre d'échanger avec vous
directement merci beaucoup
c'est moi qui vous remercie madame la
Présidente bonsoir mesdames et messieurs
les députés c'est un plaisir d'être avec
vous en cette fin d'après midi et d'être
auditionné par votre délégation dont la
création récente témoigne de
l'importance que l'Assemblée nationale
accorde au sujet relatifs aux droits des
enfants comme ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse mon action
est pleinement consacrée aux élèves et
les élèves sont évidemment d'abord des
enfants et je suis certain que votre
délégation permettra de faire avancer
des questions cruciales pour nous élèves
et je sais pouvoir compter sur vous
à votre invitation je vais
fournir quelques indications liminaires
sur
les thèmes que vous avez évoqué d'abord
la question de l'éducation à la
sexualité dont dès ma prise de fonction
j'ai rappelé la nécessité et dans
l'enjeu et notamment de
respecter la loi de 2001 la lutte aussi
contre le harcèlement et le
cyber-harcèlement qui a fait la une de
l'actualité suite au drame récent des
jeunes Lucas et de ambre qui nous
rappelle l'urgence d'aller plus loin
même si beaucoup a été fait et puis
enfin si vous le souhaitez d'autres
questions qui sont des questions
importantes mais j'aurais plaisir bien
sûr à répondre
aux questions que vous aurez je vais
donc commencer par l'éducation à la
sexualité qui est effectivement une
mission obligatoire de l'éducation
nationale depuis la loi du 4 juillet
2001 et cette loi impose 4 3 pardon
séances d'éducation à la sexualité par
an à l'école au collège et au lycée
j'ai demandé une enquête à l'inspection
enfin une enquête qui a été qui a été
diligentée dès septembre pour avoir un
état des lieux et de fait on s'est
aperçu que 80 à 90% des élèves n'ont pas
eu de séances l'année dernière or nous
savons outre le respect de la loi que
cette éducation est essentielle pour
donner à notre jeunesse les clés du
respect de soi-même et des autres ils
ont besoin d'informations fiables
objectif
d'autres fondées sur des connaissances
scientifiques et ils ont besoin aussi de
connaître leurs droits et il ne faut pas
à cet égard laisser le terrain la
désinformation ensuite pour prévenir les
violences sexuelles sexistes les
discriminations les LGBT phobies les
formes de harcèlement que nous
connaissons est une manière générale
pour favoriser l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes nous avons donc un
devoir impératif de donner aux élèves
les moyens de se poser les bonnes
questions d'avoir les bons réflexes de
réfléchir sur les atteintes à la dignité
et les violences auxquelles ils peuvent
être confrontés dans la vie et sur les
réseaux
c'est d'ailleurs ce que les élèves me
disent quand je les rencontre dans les
établissements de façon extrêmement
régulière il souhaite que cette
éducation à la sexualité et lieu à
l'école et quand elle y faite d'ailleurs
ils en sont satisfaits les élèves aussi
trouvent injuste que tout le monde n'en
bénéficie pas et que il est souvent plus
facile d'en parler à l'école que dans
les familles nous devons faire plus et
mieux j'ai mobilisé les recteurs sur ces
questions parce qu'il faut que tous les
professeurs puissent dispenser cet
enseignement obligatoire on a publié un
ensemble de ressources pédagogiques fin
septembre début octobre et nous allons
renforcer la formation des professeurs
d'une manière générale des agents de
l'éducation nationale
sur la lutte contre le mot phobie à
l'école comme je l'ai annoncé la semaine
dernière j'ai décidé que dans chaque
académie des groupes de sensibilisation
de prévention et d'action contre les
LGBT phobies devaient être créés il en
existe déjà dans quelques académiques
qui fonctionnent bien comme à Paris ou
dans l'est et d'ailleurs j'aurais demain
l'occasion d'inaugurer un séminaire de
formation nationale sur le sujet
pour que cette politique soit effective
et efficace il faut accompagner les
équipes éducatives et aussi mieux
répondre aux questions que se posent les
élèves
sur le harcèlement scolaire je vous
rappellerai ces quelques chiffres qui
permettent de prendre conscience de
l'ampleur du phénomène un élève sur 10
et victime de harcèlement à un moment ou
un autre de sa trajectoire scolaire ça
représente un total d'environ 600 000
collégiens illiciens qui ont eu le
sentiment d'avoir été harcelés l'année
dernière face à cela nous avons
développé une politique active de
sensibilisation et de prévention des
traitements et de traitement pardon des
situations de harcèlement avec la
généralisation du programme PHARE depuis
la rentrée 2022 à toutes les écoles
élémentaires et tous les collèges pour
ceux qui concerne les lycées le
programme phare pour l'instant et
facultatif il est possible mais il n'est
pas obligatoire ce programme PHARE comme
vous le savez c'est un programme de
prévention et de lutte contre le qui
mêle une approche globale
qui intègre tous les acteurs finalement
au niveau de l'établissement avec d'une
part des adultes références 5 des élèves
ambassadeurs 10 élèves par collège et
puis un programme de formation nous
avons formé 22.000 enseignants jusqu'à
présent le tout accompagné de numéro
gratuit le 30 20 pour le harcèlement le
30 18 pour les cyber violences dans tous
les établissements il y a des affiches
qui sont généralement très visibles avec
des campagnes de communication pour
faire connaître ces numéros d'ailleurs
il y a ces numéros sont sont connus et
il
sont utilisés par les élèves d'une
manière générale particulièrement au
collège enfin il faut aussi prévenir les
situations intervenir auprès des
harceleurs voir sanctionner les
harceleurs puisque nous avons désormais
l'appui de la loi la loi Balanant comme
on l'appelle aussi du de mars 2022 si ma
mémoire est bonne qu'il faut mars 2022
de Marseille d'accord
de mars 2022 qui fait du harcèlement un
délit et qui permet de poser le droit et
d'avoir des ressources en matière de
justice pénale pour les mineurs comme
vous le savez le harcèlement ne s'arrête
plus aux portes de l'école avec le
cyber-harcèlement il se prolonge bien
au-delà de l'école dans dans l'anonymat
dans la lâcheté aussi que permettent les
réseaux sociaux j'ai eu l'occasion
d'interpeller les plateformes en
particulier Tik Tok qui est très prisé
des des jeunes pour qu'elle s'engage à
faciliter les signalements et qu'elle
déclenche plus rapidement la suppression
des contenus signalés je note quand même
que Tik Tok
à plus de rapidité pour supprimer
les contenus
mettant en cause le régime chinois que
pour supprimer des contenus qui posent
des problèmes les problèmes dont nous
parlons et enfin nous développons à
l'école la sensibilisation aux bons
usages du du numérique avec des
programmes dont je pourrais vous parler
si vous le souhaitez donc voilà ce que
je voulais vous dire en guise
d'introduction il y a évidemment
d'autres sujets des sujets relatifs aux
violences des sujets relatifs à l'école
inclusive si vous le souhaitez mais je
répondrai aux questions qui me seront
posées d'une manière générale je
voudrais simplement terminer en
rappelant que l'éducation est un droit
universel et fondamental pour nos
enfants son accès est inconditionnel
doit être inconditionnel nous avons des
engagements je dirais à la fois
constitutionnel internationaux à ce
sujet et donc c'est tout le sens de mon
action tant que ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse l'école et
le lieu qui rassemble les enfants dans
une dans une unité de lieu et de temps
c'est le lieu privilégié aussi où le
repérage des situations difficiles peut
s'exercer ou les actions de prévention
et d'accompagnement peuvent s'exercer et
c'est bien c'est bien évidemment dans ce
sens là que nous allons et donc je vous
remercie
merci Monsieur mich je vous propose de
laisser la parole à un orateur par
groupe mes chers collègues je vous
propose comme d'habitude de s'en tenir à
deux minutes pour laisser le temps après
au ministre de répondre et surtout s'il
y a des approfondissements que vous
souhaitez voir à ce moment-là alors pour
commencer Caroline janvier pour le
groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre depuis votre prise de fonction
vous avez pris à bras le corps le sujet
de l'égalité des chances et c'est
heureux en travaillant sur la maîtrise
des savoirs fondamentaux sur la lutte
contre les inégalités mais aussi sur le
sujet évidemment central et l'actualité
malheureusement nous le rappelle de la
lutte contre le harcèlement car nous
savons tous ici combien un cadre serein
et bien permet un enfant de s'épanouir
et d'apprendre dans ces sujets de
relatif à l'égalité des chances il y a
évidemment la question et vous l'avez
mentionné de l'inclusion des enfants en
situation de handicap qui est une
priorité comme vous le savez la France a
été condamnée par l'ONU l'année dernière
en ce qui concerne précisément son
modèle d'inclusion des élèves en
situation de handicap et je rappelle un
certain nombre de principes qui sont nés
de d'une loi de 2005 le premier c'est
évidemment l'intégration l'accueil de
tous les enfants de la République soit
au porteur ou non d'un handicap et le
second est bien c'est de ne pas faire de
distinction entre les types de handicap
car on sait bien qu'ils sont très
différents très variables qu'il s'agisse
d'un handicap physique mental sensoriel
cognitif et il faut dans chacun de ces
cas-là et bien organiser aménager
l'accompagnement et les apprentissages
le rapport récent de la Défenseur des
droits qui était publié en août montre
que 20% de Décines dont elle fait
l'objet concernant les enfants et bien
relève d'un accueil d'un mauvais accueil
de ces élèves handicapés et donc il est
important de continuer à travailler sur
différents aspects on aborde ici trois
mais il y en a d'autres la question de
l'attractivité du métier d'aesh la
formation des enseignants on voit bien
que pour bien accompagner pour
accueillir un enfant il faut évidemment
des effectifs moins importants mais il
faut aussi que les enseignants ne se
retrouvent pas dans des situations
compliquées face à des enfants
qui ne pour lequel ils ne sont pas
formés et enfin la question de et bien
du décloisonnement entre le secteur
spécialisé et le et le milieu
diordinaire voilà qu'est-ce que
pensez-vous de ces de ces pistes et
quels sont et bien quels sont vos pistes
de travail sur ce sujet là je vous
remercie merci beaucoup j'ai madame
Parmentier pour le rassemblement
national
pardonnez-moi en 2021 plus d'une femme
sur 5 et près d'un homme sur six
témoignés avoir subi des violences
intra-familiales avant l'âge de 15 ans
ses agressions c'est violences physiques
sexuelles émotionnelles ou psychologique
sont spécialement difficiles à déceler
et à combattre car elle touche on le
sait à l'environnement proche à la
famille à l'intime détecter instruire et
prouver un cas de violence
intrafamiliale est ainsi
particulièrement difficile et délicat
notre assemblée c'est saisi de cette
question si spécifique et débattra très
prochainement à ce sujet pour agir mieux
je suis convaincue que l'école est un
lieu crucial où l'équipe éducative peut
repérer
identifier puis alerter sur la situation
d'un enfant victime de ce type de
violence néanmoins nous savons très bien
que les enfants ont évidemment du mal à
relater de tel fait à identifier le sens
de certains actes et à exprimer ce qu'il
ressent tout ce qu'ils ont vécu monsieur
le ministre de nombreux enseignants
système et AVS j'en ai eu le témoignage
se sente isolés démunis et
insuffisamment formés pour faire face à
de tels cas la prévention la formation
de l'ensemble de ces professionnels
pourrait permettre d'améliorer la
situation quel serait selon vous les
progrès possibles dans l'approche et la
préparation de l'équipe éducative à une
détection plus efficace de ces cas de
violences intrafamidales
je vous remercie merci à vous pour elle
et fille monsieur Walter merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre je vais
continuer sur ce thème le rapport que la
commission indépendante sur l'inceste et
les violences sexuelles faites aux
enfants à publier le 31 mars dernier
dont les conclusions intermédiaires sont
aussi effrayantes que salutaire trace 4
d'action et liste 20 préconisations
courageuses concrètes et réalisables
parmi ces préconisations je voudrais
insister sur un point qui vous concerne
plus directement
l'accompagnement nécessaire auprès des
professionnels de l'enfance et de la
jeunesse et donc entre autres des
professeurs de votre ministère je fais
partie de ces maîtres d'écoles qui après
la publication de nouvelles études au
début de l'année 2021 ont dû entrer en
classe chaque matin on se demandant
lequel ou lesquels de leurs élèves
étaient victimes d'inceste cette
question terrible avait un corollaire
comment en tant qu'enseignant repérer
traiter réparer et prévenir des
violences qui paraissent impliquent les
familles comment y faire face en adulte
en pédagogue en éducateur quand parfois
souvent cela faisait écho à des
histoires personnelles intimes et
douloureuses des enseignants eux-mêmes
dans cette situation de désarroi le mot
est faible nous avons été laissés
totalement complètement absolument seul
c'est malheureusement encore le cas
aujourd'hui malgré les avancées récentes
dont vous avez parlé la formation
initiale et continue des enseignants
reste notoirement insuffisantes leur
accompagnement sur le terrain également
ma question est donc la suivante comment
comptez-vous remédier à cette situation
alors que notre école reste le premier
lieu de socialisation des enfants
français et devrait donc être le premier
rempart contre les violences qui leur
sont faites je vous remercie de votre
écoute et de vos réponses
merci beaucoup pour les républicains
monsieur portier merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre nous
sommes dans la délégation au droit des
enfants et comme vous le savez s'il y a
un droit auquel je suis attaché comme
beaucoup ici c'est le droit à
l'éducation et aujourd'hui on est obligé
de reconnaître que le compte n'est pas
tout à fait et que la France manque
encore à plusieurs de ses engagements et
j'insisterai sur deux points d'abord le
handicap qui a été évoqué tout à l'heure
et ensuite l'orientation sur le handicap
les délais de remise des matériels
pédagogiques adaptés sont aujourd'hui
inappropriés et je vous interpellé à ce
sujet par question écrite il y a
quelques mois sans réponse
malheureusement mais je me permets de le
rappeler en espérant en avoir une j'y
compte bien et je j'espère que vous
serez sensible le 8 novembre vous
indiquez devant nos collègues sénateurs
que tous les enfants ne pouvaient pas
être en milieu ordinaire on est d'accord
sur sur ce point
même plus loin monsieur le ministre
comment est-ce qu'on peut aujourd'hui
accepter que le budget de l'éducation
soit devenu le cash misère qui sert à
cacher en réalité le refus d'investir
sur les politiques du handicap elle-même
parce que c'est ça le constat que font
aujourd'hui les acteurs de terrain et
puis sur l'orientation ensuite
évidemment on supprime aujourd'hui des
heures de technologie au collège je peux
pas ne pas en parler pour finir en
réalité ce qui n'a pas été fait à
l'école primaire et je dois vous avouer
que jamais je n'aurais imaginer que l'on
puisse en arriver là en France c'est un
double échec c'est un échec d'abord pour
le primaire et un des aveux pour ses
enseignants en tout cas les vécu comme
tel aujourd'hui sur le terrain et c'est
ensuite un échec pour l'apprentissage
technique et scientifique que l'on
sacrifie sans état d'âme
merci beaucoup pour le groupe modem
Erwan Balanant
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre vous avez rappelé la loi du 2
mars 2022 sur le harcèlement scolaire je
connais votre implication sur le sujet
nous avons longuement parlé la loi
repose sur trois piliers importants qui
sont indissociables la prévention
l'accompagnement la protection alors
le drame à Épinal nous rappelle le volet
protection et nous avons vu son
efficacité mais j'aimerais que ce volet
protection ne servent plus dans notre
pays et que les cas de harcèlement
scolaire n'arrivent pas jusqu'au pénal
et je sais que vous partagez évidemment
cette idée et donc pour cela il nous
reste les deux autres volets qui sont la
prévention et l'accompagnement vous
l'avez dit le programme phare se déploie
dans les écoles et au collège mais vous
avez nous avais dit qu'il ne les restait
facultatif dans les lycées un article 1
de notre loi sur la prévention rend
obligatoire la prévention et
l'accompagnement des victimes dans tous
les établissements scolaires de France
public privé sous contrat donc comment
comment peut-on vérifier
l'effectivité de cette prévention que
doit-on mettre en place pour vérifier
l'effetivité de cette prévention un
troisième point et un dernière question
pardon vous le savez cette loi faisait
suite à un rapport dans lequel j'avais
fait un certain nombre de propositions
qui n'étaient pas non plus qui n'étaient
pas d'ordre législative et en
particulier c'était la première des
propositions c'était de faire une grande
étude chiffrée scientifique sur l'état
des lieux du harcèlement scolaire en
France
études qui pourraient être réactualisée
régulièrement et qui pourrait mettre qui
pourrait être
comment dire médiatiser par un baromètre
baromètre annuel de l'état de la du
scolaire dans notre France dans notre
pays et qui permettrait cette étude
aussi de développer la recherche parce
que nous savons je pense que nous avons
encore des progrès à faire sur les
outils pédagogiques les outils de
prévention sur le sujet donc monsieur le
ministre que pensez-vous de cette idée
d'avoir une grande étude chiffrée parce
que les chiffres aujourd'hui vous avez
parlé de un enfant sur 10 mais parfois
c'est plus parfois c'est moins et moi
qui croit pense être un député assez
spécialiste de la question du
harcèlement scolaire je suis incapable
d'objectiver clairement le nombre
d'enfants aujourd'hui harcelé donc voici
une piste de travail que je vous soumets
merci beaucoup et pour terminer ce
premier tour de table madame Francesca
Pasquini pour le groupe écologiste
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre la santé est une des missions
fondamentales de l'école en tant que
ministre de l'éducation nationale vous
devez vous assurer que l'institution
remplit cette mission et qu'elle
respecte les conventions et droits en
vigueur en l'occurrence l'article 24 de
la Convention internationale des droits
de l'enfant indique que les États
s'efforcent de garantir qu'aucun enfant
ne soit privé du droit d'avoir accès aux
services médicaux de plus le code de
l'éducation rappelle l'obligation pour
les élèves de bénéficier d'actions de
prévention et d'information de visite
médicale et de dépistage obligatoire qui
constituent leur parcours de santé dans
le système scolaire néanmoins le rapport
de 2020 de la Cour des comptes et sans
équivoque sur la détérioration du
système de santé au sein des écoles on
dénombre seulement 900 médecins
scolaires pour plus de 12 millions
d'élèves au-delà au-delà des médecins
scolaires un infirmier pour 1300 élèves
et un psychologue pour 1500 et aussi un
assistant social pour 4500 élèves
souvent affectés à plusieurs
établissements
cela reste loin d'être à la hauteur des
besoins loin d'être à la hauteur des
problèmes médicaux sociaux et
psychologiques rencontrés par les élèves
si l'école est un lieu d'apprentissage
elle a aussi vocation à être un point
d'accès à la santé mais ce manque de
personnel ce système de médecine
scolaire fragilisé ce sont autant de
situations préoccupantes qui ne sont pas
décelées en amont et qui ne seront
jamais identifiés par la communauté
éducative ces manquements de
l'institution accroissent les risques
auxquels sont finalement exposés les
enfants cette situation est d'autant
plus déplorable que l'éducation
nationale repousse certainement tendue
d'associations qui pourraient
accompagner ce parcours de santé et de
dépistage dans le système scolaire je
citerai à titre d'exemple d'association
les papillons qui a essayé d'aide
dialoguer avec votre administration sans
obtenir de retour à ce jour Monsieur le
Ministre voici ma question pensez-vous
qu'un système de médecine scolaire aussi
fragile peut répondre aux nouveaux défis
et urgences qui se présentent à lui
merci beaucoup mes chers collègues pour
avoir respecté les deux minutes ce qui
va nous permettre de laisser le ministre
répondent largement merci
merci mesdames et messieurs les députés
pour vos questions certaines d'ailleurs
se recoupent et donc je ferai des
réponses synthétiques si vous me le
permettez en commençant madame la
députée par la question de l'inclusion
qui est évidemment une un grand
mouvement que celui de l'école inclusive
depuis
2005 nous avons actuellement 430
000 enfants situations de handicap en
milieu ordinaire si tu ne progression
tout à fait remarquable qui s'est
accentué ces dernières années
face à cela nous avons comme vous le
savez
créer des postes d'Ash en grand nombre
4000 par an ces dernières années 4000
sont prévus pour le budget 2023 132000
aesh en tout c'est le deuxième métier de
l'éducation nationale je le note au
passage avec un aesh pour 7 à 8
professeur c'est considérable et
pourtant cela ne suffit pas les demandes
sont importantes les notifications
arrivent presque quotidiennement de la
part des MDPH et on peut dire que c'est
le système entier qui est embolisé avec
un manque de place du côté des IME des
classes Ulysse pleines et puis un manque
d'aosh et donc cette situation pose à la
fois la question de l'attractivité du
métier de SH que vous avez souligné nous
augmentons leur rémunération de 10% à
compter de la rentrée 2023 après une
augmentation et la création de prime
d'éducation prioritaire pour les avsh
également les AED à compter du 1er
janvier les primes n'ont pas encore été
versées mais elles seront versées de
manière à couvrir le mois de janvier
mais cette la question de l'attractivité
elle se pose aussi en relation avec le
nombre d'heures effectuées par les aesh
24 heures ça n'est pas suffisant pour
avoir un salaire attractif nous devons
tendre vers les 35 heures comme le
président de la République s'y est
engagé et de ce point de vue là nous
faisons des progrès puisque nous
parvenons nous avons précisé ça dans une
circulaire le 4 janvier à cette fiche de
paix unique qui permet de regrouper le
paiement scolaire et le paiement
périscolaire tout en respectant la
décision du Conseil d'État qui nous
enjoint de ne pas rémunérer le
périscolaire et donc nous allons nous
faire ensuite rembourser des sommes
correspondant au périscolaire par les
collectivités donc nous tendons vers les
35 heures c'est très important pour les
aesh et j'ajoute à cela la CDI
de trois ans au lieu de 6 ans bref la
construction si l'on veut de carrière
message qui soit correctement rémunéré
mais au-delà de cette question d'autres
questions se posent et c'est pour cela
que nous travaillons en vue de la
Conférence nationale sur le handicap qui
va se tenir au printemps 2023 qui va
nous permettre d'enclencher l'acte 2 de
l'école inclusive en effet la réponse ne
peut pas être simplement la création de
poste d'Ash toujours insuffisante d'une
certaine façon compte tenu de l'état
général du système il faut donc repenser
d'une manière générale et je vais tout à
fait le sens de vos propos
repenser les liens entre le milieu
ordinaire et le milieu
médico-éducatif il y a des expériences
tout à fait intéressantes qui sont
menées ici et là j'ai eu le l'occasion
de le voir à Marseille par exemple il y
a quelques mois de manière à rapprocher
les soignants d'enfants a besoin
particulier mais placé en milieu
ordinaire par exemple pour ceux qui
concerne les enfants souffrant du
trouble du spectre autistique on a des
écoles avec deux salles une salle
ordinaire de cours et puis une autre
salle où ses enfants peuvent se rendre
en cas de crise ou en cas de difficultés
pour s'isoler et être dans un milieu
particulier on trouve également pour ses
enfants des soins qui sont
amenés si je puis dire en tout cas qui
sont à proximité immédiates de
l'établissement en question c'est donc
tout à fait dans ce sens que nous
travaillons y compris avec les
associations
représentatives en vue d'aboutir à
quelque chose de significatif au
printemps prochain ça inclut aussi la
question de la formation des enseignants
je crois que c'est un élément tout à
fait essentiel nous y réfléchissons
notamment dans le cadre des nouvelles
missions que nous allons proposer aux
Esséniens c'est en discussion
actuellement avec les organisations
syndicales pour à la fois se servir des
pials mais aussi se servir d'enseignants
qui seraient des enseignants à la fois
formateurs comment dirais-je référent et
disposant d'une formation qui permettent
de
d'intermédié avec leurs collègues
leurs collègues enseignants dans les
établissements du premier et du second
degré donc cette question de la
formation est importante j'ajoute
peut-être monsieur le député portier
votre question sur les matériels
pédagogiques adaptés alors je si vous
n'avez pas de réponse je vais veiller à
ce qu'elle vous soit fournie il me
semblait néanmoins qu'on avait répondu
alors peut-être pas formellement sous la
forme de demande qui pouvait être faites
aux Fonds d'innovation pédagogique que
nous mettons en place qui est doté de
150 millions d'euros et qui commence à
abonder les projets d'innovation
pédagogique et nous sommes tout à fait
ouvert à ce que des matériels
pédagogiques puissent être
demandé dans ce cadre là lorsque je
disais que tous les enfants ne peuvent
pas être en milieu ordinaire c'était une
constatation d'aujourd'hui mais là le
souhait et je pense notre mission c'est
de pouvoir accueillir tous les enfants
mais dans les dans des conditions qui
soient différentes des conditions
d'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui l'école telle
qu'elle est ne peut pas accueillir tous
les enfants et donc la réflexion si vous
voulez de l'acte 2 de l'école inclusive
c'est comment fait-on en rapprochant le
médico-éducatif des milieux ordinaires
pour que des enfants avec des situations
de handicap plus marquées puissent être
accueillis voyez en agrafage si je puis
dire entre l'école et le milieu
ordinaire mais je pense que notre devoir
c'est de penser l'école comme pouvant
accueillir tous les enfants mais
certainement pas dans les circonstances
actuelles deux questions ont été posées
par vous madame Parmentier et vous
monsieur Walter à propos des violences
intra familiales et de leur détection
nous avons certainement des progrès à
faire de ce côté là mais nous utilisons
néanmoins un livret de formation qui a
été élaboré par la civisme et qui est
assez complet je suppose que vous l'avez
que le que vous l'avez consulté il est
vrai que l'école c'est le premier lieu
de détection des formes de violence
subies par les enfants y compris dans le
milieu familial c'est le premier lieu de
signalement de ces enfants cela peut se
faire par le biais des assistants
sociaux assistantes sociales ça peut le
faire ça peut se faire aussi par le
biais des enseignants et il y a en plus
du livret de formation un vademekum que
nous avons publié à destination des
enseignants et des agents de l'éducation
nationale pour les aider à détecter ces
situations nous pouvons toujours faire
mieux et je suis bien en accord avec
vous sur le fait que la formation
initiale est des enseignants doit
inclure cette question de la détection
des situations de violence vécues par
les enfants dans leur comportement
éventuellement par les traces physiques
qu'ils peuvent avoir
à propos de de questions
de harcèlement puis je viendrai à un
point peut-être plus latéral par rapport
à votre délégation mais j'y répondrai
quand même la question du harcèlement
toujours donc à propos de
des questions de
de Monsieur Balanant pardon j'y arrive
votre
loi est importante non pas parce qu'elle
oblige à aller au pénal même si la
justice pénale des mineurs a toujours
une dimension éducative elle est pas
comparable de ce point de vue là la
justice pénale des majeurs parce que
d'une part la loi à une dimension
symbolique mais vous avez raison le
programme phare a une à visa à faire en
quelque sorte prendre de reconscience de
la part du harceleur
de la réalité et de la gravité de ces
actes et donc le programme phare dans
une logique de non-violence en fait
c'est la philosophie de la non-violence
vise au fond à éduquer à élever même le
harceleur pour que à l'issue de la de la
démarche le harcelé soit réparé mais que
le harceleur sans en soit grandis et
j'ai eu d'ailleurs l'occasion de
rencontrer des élèves engagés dans le
programme phare qui est qui était
d'anciens harceleur ce qui montre bien
que ce programme là où il a été
expérimenté dans 6 académies pendant
deux années avant d'être généralisée à
la rentrée dernière a des résultats
intéressants mais je pense que la loi
pose symboliquement le harcèlement comme
daily et cela est important je retiens
l'idée d'un état des lieux précis parce
que c'est vrai que les chiffres
fluctuent en matière de harcèlement l'un
des effets de la généralisation du
programme PHARE tout au moins en ce qui
concerne l'école élémentaire et le
collège c'est qu'on aura plus de
signalement il est normal d'avoir plus
de signalement ça n'est pas une mauvaise
chose puisque
l'idée c'est aussi de faire apparaître
ce qui sinon se dissout dans l'école et
n'apparaît pas visiblement donc le
programme phare a un effet de qui pourra
asseoir une statistique plus précise et
je suis tout à fait en accord avec vous
sur la nécessité d'avoir des données
précises
à propos de votre question madame
Pasquini le système de santé nous
reconnaissons évidemment les difficultés
du système de santé ces difficultés
elles ne tiennent pas tant à la création
de posts ou à l'absence de création de
poste que à des postes non pourvu car en
ce qui concerne la médecine scolaire il
y a environ 900 médecins scolaires mais
il y a beaucoup plus de postes mais ce
sont des postes vacants il y a environ
un tiers de postes vacants en matière de
médecine scolaire beaucoup plus
d'ailleurs dans certains départements
ruraux ou les médecins scolaires ont
quasiment disparu il est devenu
extrêmement difficile de recruter des
médecins scolaires c'est moins vrai pour
les infirmiers et les infirmières c'est
moins vrai également pour
nous avons augmenté le de 22%, le nombre
le recrutement de psychologues de
l'éducation nationale au budget
2022 et également au budget 2023 donc
nous avons une réflexion à avoir sur le
système de santé en en tenant compte des
difficultés de recrutement que que nous
avons on pourrait multiplier par deux le
poste le nombre de postes de médecins
scolaires que ça ne changerait rien à la
situation pour le résumé donc
actuellement il y a une mission qui a
été confiée à trois inspections
générales Ligas l'inspection générale de
l'éducation du sport et de la Recherche
et puis
l'inspection générale de
l'administration je crois qui vont
achever leur travail en février ou en
mars ce qui permettra au ministre de la
santé et à moi-même de formuler des
réponses un peu globales à cette
situation de une crise de du système de
santé scolaire je reconnais très
volontiers que la situation actuelle
n'est pas une situation
satisfaisante donc nous attendons et
puis nous vous ferons des propositions
si vous le je serai heureux de revenir
vers vous pour faire pour faire des des
propositions en matière de réforme du
système de santé scolaire parce que nous
sommes en situation de crise aujourd'hui
en ce qui concerne votre des questions
je reviens vers vous monsieur le député
portier à propos de de la suppression de
la l'heure de technologie en 6e ce n'est
pas suppression de la technologie au
collège nous reconfigurons la
technologie pour le cycle 4 c'est-à-dire
pour les classes de cinquième quatrième
et troisième
nous sommes au travail évidemment pour
reconfigurer la technologie en cinquième
quatrième et certainement pas pour
l'abandonner mais il faut reconnaître
une situation qui est celle quelle est
c'est à dire ce n'est pas une situation
satisfaisante mais environ 25% des
élèves de 6e à l'entrée en 6e ont des
difficultés de lecture en fluence en
particulier il y a un petit tiers ont
des difficultés en mathématiques il faut
nous saisir de cette situation c'est une
situation absolument inacceptable elle
est inacceptable inacceptable aussi d'un
point de vue social je dirais ce sont
les élèves les plus fragiles ceux des
milieux les plus défavorisés qui ont les
difficultés les plus importantes donc
moi ce que je dis c'est que la priorité
des priorités c'est que nos élèves c'est
qu'on va on vise les fragilités de nos
élèves si c'est les quatre opérations on
va travailler toute l'année sur les
quatre opérations pour résoudre cette
difficulté si c'est une difficulté de
lecture on va on va travailler sur cette
difficulté de lecture et on repense
l'enseignement du moyen et de la sixième
en centrant sur les savoirs fondamentaux
on a besoin en mathématiques il y a un
rapport très clair de l'Inspection
Générale qui le dit on a besoin de
calcul mental il ne faut pas laisser
tomber le calcul mental j'ai insisté
beaucoup sur la dictée mais ce n'est pas
seulement la dictée c'est l'écriture on
est on écrit plus suffisamment en court
moyen là aussi l'inspection générale
nous indique que 7% du temps
hebdomadaire est consacré à l'écriture
mais l'écriture ce n'est pas que la
dictée c'est les rédactions c'est les
cahiers d'écrivain c'est tout ce qu'on
voudra l'écriture est une nécessité
absolue pour nos élèves et pas
simplement de remplir les phrases à
trous en mettant les verbes conjugués et
les adverbes il faut que nos élèves
écrivent c'est pour moi c'est crucial et
ça ne se résume pas à la dictée donc on
met le paquet si vous me permettez
l'expression en court moyen et en
sixième sur ses savoirs fondamentaux
mais on ne laisse pas tomber la
technologie
quant aux questions relatives aux études
supérieures non on ne jette pas les
élèves ou les vers le vers les études
supérieures les études les tous ceux qui
relèvent des métiers techniques j'ai eu
l'occasion d'insister notamment sur la
place des filles et sur la
sous-représentation des filles dans les
filières techniques technologiques et
certaines filières scientifiques est une
énorme difficulté si on veut remplir nos
objectifs en matière de formation de
techniciens et d'ingénieur il faut
beaucoup plus de femmes et de filles
dans ces métiers là la revalorisation
des voies professionnelles dans le lycée
et dans les formations supérieures
courtes et quelque chose auquel nous
sommes particulièrement attachés moi je
suis aussi celui qui considère que il y
a de multiples voies de réussite
scolaires la réussite scolaire ça n'est
pas la réussite par les études je dirais
les plus classiques par le cursus
honorum le plus classique les études
techniques des études traditionnels sont
une manière de réussir à l'école mais
nous avons besoin d'asseoir les
fondamentaux j'insiste beaucoup sur ce
point pardon on est un tout petit peu
voilà on s'écarte un tout petit peu du
centre de la délégation mais je
rebondissait sur votre question
ok très bien
merci pour ces premières réponses
j'avais monsieur fait qui m'avait
indiqué vouloir intervenir
merci merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre effectivement voilà
vous avez abordé beaucoup de
points notamment sur ce que je voulais
parler au niveau du harcèlement et du
handicap
aussi permettez-moi aussi quand même
d'avoir quand même de rendre hommage à
toutes nos équipes éducatives les
enseignants et enseignants et puis
toutes les personnes qui avaient au
quotidien pour le bien-être de nos
enfants et je pense notamment aux aesh
cependant je connais aussi votre combat
contre le harcèlement scolaire et tout
votre attachement aussi au bien-être à
l'école et de nombreux facteurs entre en
jeu sur ce point et forcer de constater
que sur ce sur ces champs thérapeutiques
de nombreux points n'ont pas été
investis dans le milieu scolaire je vais
ici parler de techniques alternatives
qui ont déjà fait l'objet d'études et
ont démontré leur efficacité leur
intérêt aussi comme la méditation
et donc à ce titre je souhaitais
connaître votre position sur cette
notion de bien-être à l'école pour tous
les enfants pendant le temps scolaire
merci
merci à vous j'ai madame stambach noir
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je voudrais insister sur la
question des aesh parce que vendredi
dernier notamment une collègue de
renaissance expliquée en commission des
finances que les accompagnants d'élèves
en situation de handicap assume leur
statut précaire parce qu'elles ont je
cite leur mercredi et les vacances
scolaires alors moi je ne sais pas
quelles assistantes elle a parlé mais
j'ai rencontré surtout des aesh en
souffrance parce qu'elle n'arrive pas
n'arrive plus à faire leur travail dans
de bonnes conditions et la vérité c'est
qu'elle subisse les temps partiels et
tendre vers 35 heures paraît en
l'occurrence bien irréaliste elles sont
trop peu nombreuses et du coup épuisées
parce que grâce aux fameux pial les
pôles inclusives d'accompagnement
localisés mis en place donc pour gérer
la pénurie personnelle elles
accompagnent parfois quatre cinq six
sept enfants avec des besoins totalement
différents dans des établissements
différents et tout ça sans
reconnaissance avec des contrats
précaires et un salaire moyen de 760
euros la belle vie quoi donc en plus ce
sont encore elles qui avec leur carrière
hachées souffriraient le plus de la
réforme des retraites que votre
gouvernement veut faire passer en et
derrière ces femmes ce sont nos enfants
qui souffrent avec elles parce que le
résultat de ce mépris institutionnel de
cette école inclusive low cost ce sont
aussi des milliers d'enfants
partiellement ou complètement des
scolarisés juste pour illustrer dans
l'école Renan sur ma circonscription qui
est un réplique donc en quartier très
populaire en éducation très prioritaire
il y a deux aesh pour 8 élèves qui
nécessitent un accompagnement à temps
plein et 7 qui était en attente de
notification à la rentrée donc soit vous
aurez fait le calcul 2 aesh pour 15
élèves donc là l'état manquait son
devoir monsieur le ministre car vous
l'avez rappelé le droit à l'éducation
est un droit universel et fondamental
dans notre pays à la France insoumise
nous proposons et demandons la création
d'un véritable corps de fonctionnaires
pour les ESH avec une formation et un
salaire digne de ce nom parce que 10%
d'augmentation sur moins de 100 de 800
euros pardon ça reste largement en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté et ce sont
des métiers essentiels qui devraient
être valorisés alors Monsieur le
Ministre allez vous vraiment agir pour
redonner leur lettre de noblesse votre
métier agir pour ces femmes pour ses
enfants qui sont aujourd'hui méprisés
merci
merci j'ai madame Martin
merci madame la Présidente de Monsieur
le Ministre comme vous le voyez dans
cette délégation le sujet de
l'accompagnement des enfants en
situation de handicap et celui des aesh
nous mobilise particulièrement mais
c'est un enjeu très important pour
garantir l'égal accès à l'éducation de
nos enfants en situation de handicap
vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure
l'arrêt du Conseil d'État à évoqué le
fait que tout enfant en situation de
handicap a le droit d'avoir un aesh
pendant le temps périscolaire également
et dans le même temps cet arrêt a fait
porter le coût financier et le coût
organisationnel de ce temps périscolaire
et de l'intervention de ces aesh à ce
moment-là aux collectivités
territoriales alors c'est un sujet sur
lequel l'Association des maires de
France notamment vous a souvent alerté
aujourd'hui toutes les communes et la
plupart des communes et des
collectivités territoriales vous le
savez sont en tension financièrement et
cela peut créer des inégalités sur le
territoire français des inégalités aussi
et des ruptures de prise en charge entre
des enfants qui peuvent être pris en
charge par les collectivités parce
qu'elles ont les moyens et la capacité
structurelles et les collectivités qui
ne le peuvent pas donc ma question est
celle-ci est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous
qu'est-ce que vous envisagez
concrètement pour soutenir les
collectivités dans la mise en place de
ces dispositifs pendant le temps
périscolaire et la cantine merci
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre j'ai plusieurs sujets le
premier concerne la question de la
transidentité chez les jeunes
on observe chez nos voisins européens
une nette augmentation du nombre de
jeunes enfants qui sont opérés pour une
transition physique d'un genre vers un
autre on voit aussi de plus en plus que
des militants favorables à ces
opérations peuvent intervenir dans les
établissements scolaires or il n'est pas
démontré médicalement en tout cas que
les personnes qui souffrent de dysphorie
de genre se sentent mieux après une
telle opération on voit notamment des
cas importantes dépression donc c'était
d'automutilation d'envie suicidaire qui
sont toujours présents après des
opérations alors je considère que
l'école est un avant tout un lieu
d'apprentissage et vos propos peuvent
laisser le laisser à penser et non pas
un lieu de militantisme
un certain nombre d'interventions
notamment à Brest en décembre dernier
dans un lycée fait état
association qui promouvent c'est
question d'identité de genre et de
transidentité avec un certain nombre de
questions très saugrenues comme est-ce
que je suis bien du genre féminin est-ce
que je suis vraiment une femme et ce que
je fais ce que je fais en tant que femme
me plaît vraiment donc on a un certain
nombre de sujets par rapport à ces
interventions qui ont lieu dans nos
établissements scolaires et face à nos
enfants alors ma question est simple
quelles sont les conditions d'agrément
que le ministère met en place pour
justifier et en tout cas examiner les
interventions de ces associations un
autre sujet aussi qui tend à prendre un
peu plus de place dans nos
établissements scolaires aussi
principalement pas principalement mais
aussi de plus en plus dans
l'enseignement supérieur c'est la place
de l'écriture inclusive un certain
nombre de circulaires proscrivent
l'utilisation de l'usage de l'écriture
inclusive or nous rendu compte que dans
les faits cet usage se développe de plus
en plus de les établissements scolaires
notamment par les enseignants mais aussi
dans des administrations plus largement
quelles sont les mesures au sein du
ministère de l'Éducation nationale ce
qui sont mises en place pour
circonscrire cet usage de l'écriture
inclusif qui est écriture inclusive
pardon qui ne porte que d'inclusifs que
le nom puisque on le sait bien à
certains nombre de personnes en
situation de handicap ont de grandes
difficultés à accomplir à comprendre la
langue française avec cet usage et un
dernier point très rapide au sujet de
l'instruction en famille nous avons
auditionné avec une commission votre
dgsco qui m'avait assuré vous
transmettre les chiffres relatifs à
l'instruction en famille aujourd'hui
nous n'en avons toujours pas
connaissance donc nous aimerions
également les avoir merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre me permet de
rajouter quelques points puisque après
on aura fini la salle des questions
vous parlez de difficultés à l'entran
6ème de lecture et d'écriture nous
savons que beaucoup de choses ont été
faites notamment sur le dédoulement des
classes en quartiers politiques de la
ville mais également sur le plafonnement
des classes de grandes sections CP CE1 à
24 qui est une bonne mesure est-ce qu'il
ne faudrait pas pour justement éviter de
repousser les problématiques de lecture
agriculture en 6e généraliser ce 24 par
classe sur toutes les classes de
primaires CE2 CM1 CM2 étant donné qu'on
a une baisse démographique des enfants
il y a pas de problème de de à part
certaines communes de gestion de place
et je pense qu'on y gagnerait
effectivement à ce niveau là et enfin
vous avez parlé un petit peu toutes les
effectifs que ce soit médecin
ou psychologue moi je vous alerte aussi
sur les assistantes sociales éducation
nationale qui sont également en
difficulté et là où on a effectivement
de plus en plus de violences à travers
détectées et on me dit ça va monter le
rôle de ces assistantes familiales me
paraît primordial je voulais savoir si
vous alliez envisager de de j'allais
dire remonter un petit peu ce cursus et
pour terminer
j'ai commencé avec je termine avec je
suis un peu pénible là dessus
l'éducation sexuelle pour moi doit
évoluer aujourd'hui ces trois heures à
discrétion il y a pas écrit réellement
dans le programme il y a pas d'heure
fixe dessiné sur sur ces trois heures ne
devrait-on pas en faire une matière à
part entière et faire évoluer cette
éducation sexuelle sur toute la
scolarité des la maternelle avec une
éducation au corps ainsi qu'au droit des
enfants dès la maternelle et après
effectivement collège lycée sur tout ce
qui est sexualité et parentalité car
pour moi il est très important que les
enfants connaissent leurs droits et
notamment connaissent ce qu'on a le
droit de leur faire ou pas ça permet
qu'il soit victime certes mais peut-être
moins longtemps par savoir qu'on est
victime encore faut-il savoir qu'on les
merci monsieur le ministre en tout cas
des réponses que vous allez apporter à
cette deuxième sève de question
merci madame la Présidente merci
mesdames et messieurs les députés pour
toutes ces questions évidemment
importantes monsieur fait je j'avoue que
je ne connais pas bien les questions
relatives à la méditation je
votre question est une invitation à m'y
pencher finalement et donc je vous
promets que je vais regarder cette
question de la méditation je sais que ça
se développe mais je n'ai pas de de
données sur les sur les effets et sur la
manière dont les choses se passent donc
je vais me pencher sur cette question je
vous en remercie madame stambach TER
noire de mépris institutionnels il en
est évidemment pas question
certainement pas dans ma bouche ou du
côté de l'éducation nationale j'ai
reconnu j'en ai parlé précédemment que
les ash ne sont pas payés ne sont pas
rémunérés et et à hauteur
convenable et c'est pour cela que nous
allons et que nous devons aller vers les
35 heures comme je l'ai précisé à propos
des
des ash toujours
tous les enfants en situation de
handicap n'ont pas besoin
de d'aesh pendant la pause méridienne
seule un petit pourcentage
d'enfants on estime ce pourcentage entre
6 et 7% a besoin d'un accompagnement
pendant la pause méridienne les enfants
qui ont des troubles des troubles par
exemple les troubles 10 qui sont très
importants dans
cet ensemble des 430 000 enfants n'ont
pas besoin d'un accompagnement
particulier pendant la pause méridienne
donc il faut aussi voir en fonction des
besoins précis que nous avons
parler également de de la civilisation
non pas de la création d'un corps de
fonctionnaires mais de la céléisation
des aesh qui me semblent être aussi une
démarche importante et puis comme je
l'ai indiqué de la Conférence nationale
sur le handicap à propos je crois que
c'était une question de la part de
madame Martin c'est cela à propos
du vous avez rappelé donc toujours du
côté des absh la décision du du Conseil
d'État et
j'ai évoqué précédemment la circulaire
du 4 janvier à propos de la feuille de
paix unique cette circulaire a été
élaborée en concertation avec les
associations et également avec les
collectivités je pense qu'elle répond à
la demande générale en tout cas de la
part des collectivités j'ai eu plutôt
des retours positifs on va voir comment
ça se passe bien sûr et puis on pourra
ajuster mais je pense que c'est un pas
en avant parce que une fiche de paix
c'est important pour les personnes
concernées et puis ça nous permet de
tendre vers les 35 heures comme je le
disais précédemment
à propos de des questions que vous posez
madame Blin je sur de transidentité la
question des élèves des identités de
genre est une question qui est posée et
d'ailleurs elle a été explicite par une
circulaire de septembre
2021 qui se pose qui se penchent sur la
question de l'accueil du bien-être des
élèves trans qui
stipule cette circulaire que un
changement de prénom dans les je dirais
dans la dans le le fonctionnement
ordinaire de l'école pour les cartes de
cantine pour les cartes scolaires et
tout à fait possible il y a de ce point
de vue là les commissions au niveau de
chaque rectorat auquel je faisais
allusion une lune existe à Paris depuis
plusieurs années qui se penchent sur ces
questions et nous en avons fait un bilan
rapide qui indique que cela fonctionne
bien avec les familles et que nous
n'avons pas de difficultés particulières
de ce côté là en ce qui concerne les
associations et nous devons faire mieux
en ce qui concerne l'accueil des élèves
en des élèves
disons LGBT et lutter contre les LGBT
phobies que ce soit du côté des
de l'homophobie ou que ce soit du côté
de la transphobie parce que du côté de
l'homophobie le taux de suicide et
quatre fois 4 à 5 fois supérieur au taux
national et du côté de la des élèves
trans nous avons un taux de suicide qui
est 11 fois supérieur donc il faut
réfléchir et puis faire de telle sorte
que les établissements scolaires
bannissent toutes formes de harcèlement
de violence ou de discrimination à
l'égard des disons de discrimination
anti LGBT et puis également nous
accueillons en effet des associations
mais des associations elles sont agrées
il y a un double processus d'agrément
soit au niveau de chaque académie soit
au niveau national par exemple
l'association SOS Homophobie est une
association qui intervient en milieu
scolaire elle est elle est agréée
nationalement
des conditions les conditions d'agrément
ce sont des conditions qui permettent
d'examiner le contenu des de ce qui est
proposé aux élèves le sérieux il y a une
enquête qui est faite et puis il y a des
associations que l'on agréé et des
associations que l'on n'agrait pas d'une
manière générale au-delà de cette
question ce n'est pas une simple
procédure formelle sur l'écriture
inclusive
si vous faites allusion au point médian
je ne suis pas du tout amateur et
favorable au point médian mais
l'écriture inclusive ou en tout cas le
français inclusif ça peut prendre des
formes qui ne sont pas du tout des
formes problématiques si je dis
mesdames et messieurs les députés si je
dis ou si j'entends française français
c'est de l'écriture c'est une expression
inclusive qui tient compte
du féminin et du masculin moi je dis
couramment dans la conversation je peux
faire couramment allusion
aux assistances sociaux et aux
assistantes sociales ça c'est de
l'écriture ou de la parole inclusive j'y
vois pas de problème particulier je n'y
vois pas d'entor ce fait à la langue
française
si vous faites l'illusion au point
médian encore une fois ça c'est autre
chose mais personnellement comme je vous
ai dit je n'y suis pas du tout favorable
j'ai pas vu d'invasion du point médian
dans l'éducation nationale encore mais
je vous faites vous pensez sans doute à
quelque chose de de spécifique sur l'IEF
le je ne suis pas sûr qu'on est des
chiffres à vous donner je regarde
simplement les les chiffres voilà au 1er
octobre 2022 nous avons donc
voilà donc il y a 57
000 environ 57000 demandes
d'autorisation qui ont été instruites et
394 demandes on fait l'objet d'une
autorisation donc 90 % des demandes
instruites ont fait l'objet d'une
autorisation à un titre ou un autre il y
a quatre titres comme vous savez les
trois premiers ne posent pas de
difficultés c'est le titre 4 à propos de
l'existence d'une situation propre à
l'enfant motivant le projet éducatif qui
pose problème et qui amène à des
situations de contentieux ce qui est
exact c'est que les je dirais que
l'évaluation notamment au titre 4 est
inégal selon les académies il y a les
académies qui ont été plus ou moins
rigoureuses dans les réponses formulées
aux familles au titre 4 et donc nous
avons un effort à faire je dirais
d'unification et de clarification pour
ce titre 4
ça c'est c'est une certitude mais on
vous donnera tous les éléments chiffrés
si vous le si vous le souhaitez je me
tourne vers vous madame la Présidente
pour
rebondir sur vos questions à propos de
dédoublement
un mot sur l'effet du dédoublement donc
le dédoublement des classes de grandes
section qui n'est pas encore entièrement
réalisée on est à environ à 70%
l'objectif c'est de parvenir à 100% pour
la rentrée 2024 il est réalisé pour ce
qui concerne les classes de CP et C1 en
éducation prioritaire nous avons eu la
première corde de d'élèves de 6e ayant
bénéficié du dédoublement qui montre un
effet positif particulièrement pour les
rêves plus un peu moins pour les reps et
en tenant compte quand même d'un
phénomène très important dont on n'a pas
fini de mesurer les effets c'est c'est
la crise sanitaire bien que la France
est fermée ses écoles moins longtemps
que beaucoup d'autres pays il est
certain que les enfants ont souffert de
la crise sanitaire particulièrement les
enfants en éducation prioritaire ou dans
des mondes défavorisés qui qui ont subi
de plein fouet la crise sanitaire et qui
font que les effets du dédoublement ont
été parasités ou embarrassés par la
crise sanitaire donc il va falloir
attendre un peu nous sommes confiants
sur l'intérêt du dédoublement si les
deux surcroît accompagnés de changement
dans les approches pédagogiques quand on
enseigne devant 12 élèves de la même
manière que devant 24 l'effet est
positif mais pas autant que ce que l'on
peut souhaiter donc on a aussi la
question de la formation des enseignants
pour enseigner devant des groupes plus
petits mais pour l'instant je le répète
les effets sont positifs quand tu as
envisagé un dédoublement sur des corps
plus plus importantes nous n'avons
actuellement nous avons ça ne vous a pas
échappé des difficultés de recrutement
en ce qui concerne les professeurs des
écoles difficultés auxquelles nous
allons remédier mais ces difficultés
nous nous interdisent à ce stade
d'envisager autre chose qu'une
limitation à 24 une limitation à 24 qui
sera j'allais dire c'est un des effets
positifs d'une situation par ailleurs
malheureuse qui est la baisse de la
natalité en France qui se fait sentir de
manière particulièrement forte dans le
primaire moins dans le secondaire mais
dans le primaire les effectifs sont en
chute très importante ça nous offre des
possibilités entre guillemets en matière
d'encadrement mais par ailleurs la
baisse de la natalité est évidemment
préoccupante j'ai bien noté votre point
sur les assistantes sociales nous avons
besoin de recruter des assist sociaux et
des assistantes sociales je rebondis sur
l'écriture sur la parole inclusive
madame la députée je suis en accord avec
cela quant à faire de l'éducation à la
sexualité une matière à proprement
parler
là on se heurte quand même à des emplois
du temps d'élèves qui sont extrêmement
chargés il y a l'éducation à la
sexualité il y a l'éducation au
développement durable il y a l'éducation
aux médias et à l'information dont on
aurait pu parler parce que je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui peut qui
intéresse votre
votre délégation à plusieurs à plusieurs
titres donc il y a un ensemble de de
choses dont l'école doit se saisir mais
l'éducation sexualité en fait elle peut
être assurée par les professeurs de SVT
elle peut être aussi assurée par les
infirmiers infirmières scolaires c'est
souvent le cas d'ailleurs dans les
collège elle peut être aussi assurée
évidemment par les professeurs des
écoles elle peut être aussi assurée par
d'autres professeurs ça n'est pas une
obligation que le professeur de SVT du
côté de l'éducation à la sexualité
d'autant que la dimension strictement
biologique n'est une dimension de
l'éducation de la sexualité mais il y a
bien d'autres dimensions comme comme
vous l'avez souligné donc notre
préférence pour l'instant va à une
approche transverse
ce qui n'est pas une manière pour moi de
me défausser j'insiste sur l'importance
qu'il y a à assurer cette éducation à la
sexualité on va refaire une enquête à la
fin de l'année pour voir où on en est
j'insiste beaucoup quand je prends la
parole auprès des recteurs chaque mois
sur l'importance de de marteler cette
question là qui a des effets très
importants sur les relations entre
filles et garçons sur les violences
sexuelles et sexistes sur des questions
qui qui résonnent de manière très
largement au sein de l'école et puis
dans la société française donc vous vous
pouvez compter sur moi madame la
Présidente pour faire que l'on respecte
la loi j'allais dire et surtout au-delà
du respect de la loi faire que
l'éducation à la sexualité soit
correctement assuré que pour cela nous
enseignants disposent des formations et
puis des outils pédagogiques nécessaires
il y a également des associations qui
interviennent dans ce sens des
associations agrées bien entendu avec
qui nous avons généralement non
seulement passer agrément mais établi
des conventions
je vous remercie merci à vous je pense
qu'on a fait le tour des questions et ça
tombe bien puisqu'on est attendu pour
les votes vous vouliez une suspension
c'est mieux que ça vous avez vu c'est
dans le timing
je vous propose par contre de revenir
après le vote pour étudier le rapport de
Nicole dubreechira sur la proposition de
loi Isabelle Santiago qui passera la
semaine prochaine dans l'hémicycle
monsieur le ministre merci beaucoup et
on reste à votre écoute pour avancer sur
tous ces sujets qui nous mobilisent de
manière importante merci beaucoup
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
suis évidemment à votre disposition pour
échanger sur ces sujets merci beaucoup